and the reason for this is because current classical methods are limited by fundamentally inefficient mathematical
descriptions of atomic structures storing and manipulating a Quantum State takes an exponential amount of resources
on a classical computer but can be done efficiently on a quantum computer and that's what makes material simulation
and chemical modeling some of the most promising application areas more specifically this could lead to
developments in carbon dioxide sequestration alternative batteries or the invention of new drugs some
algorithms that are especially relevant in this area are the variational quantum igen solver vqe which is used to
estimate certain properties of a material such as equilibrium or minimum energy states another example is the
time Dynamic simulation TDS that algorithm is used to estimate response functions or spectral properties of
materials and I also wanted to mention a newcomer sample based Quantum diagonalization which we think will we
will hearing a lot more about in the near future the next application area is optimization now optimization is pretty
ubiquitous in Computing as you can imagine so the use cases are quite numerous and varied
however some examples that we hear about a lot are portfolio optimization in finance industrial design and also
distribution and supply chain the most common algorithm you will probably hear related to optimization is the one we
have already covered in some depth the quantum approximate optimization algorithm or
qaoa lastly one area that there has been a lot of excitement for in the past few years is quantum machine learning now I
think it's fair to say that it looks like qml isn't going going to happen as soon as simulation will in all likelihood but nevertheless there are
some impressive algorithms people are working on consistently corresponding to some very important use
cases some of these possible use cases are natural language processing Network traffic analysis and even fraud
detection in financial transactions relevant algorithms in this area are the quantum support Vector
machine Quantum neural networks andant Quantum generative adversarial networks now to clarify those three
groups that we just described are broad application areas it is also worth noting that in the community there is
also benefit to groups working together who are focused on a specific topic IBM spearheaded an initiative not too long
ago called The Working groups to try to help collaborators meet and create productive Synergy in four specific
areas Healthcare and life science materials and HPC high energy physics and
optimization here are our current groups and the entities involved in those efforts if you want to hear more about
what the working groups are doing we have attached four of their white papers in the description below now like I said
I think the best thing to do at this point in the course is to spend some time exploring which sorts of problems people are working on on The Cutting
Edge of this technology and developing our intuition for knowing what types of algorith iths are going to work and how
to apply them and before we begin I just want to make it very clear that the main goal here is not to understand every
detail of the experiments this type of analysis can be very intimidating for even experts if the paper is slightly
out of your area of expertise the goal is simply to help develop an intuition for the types of problems quantum
computers are good for and how to handle them and if you're interested in the finer details and this has sparked some
ideas of your own I definitely encourage you to go and read the full papers themselves the specific use cases and
papers that we are going to be taking an in-depth look at are these first we will explore a paper that discusses
simulation of hadron Dynamics This falls into the high energy physics category next we will look at an optimization
problem specifically bias field counter adiabatic Quantum optimization and lastly we will look at yet another
simulation problem but this time focusing on mRNA a crucial molecule for
drug and therapeutic development if you're familiar or not with these papers that's no problem we are going to walk
through them all three are important papers that tackle problems of substantial size and show how quantum
computers are beginning to be used as another method of scientific inquiry first up is simulating hadron
Dynamics and we're going to delve into a paper by Martin Savage's group at the University of Washington called Quantum
simulations of hadron Dynamics in the schwinger model using 112
cubits if you're not a high energy physicist you might still be familiar with the term hadron such as in the
Large Hadron Collider or the LHC which is the giant particle accelerator 27 kilometers in circumference that made it
possible to finally observe the higs Bon now I had is a subatomic composite particle made up of other small
particles called quarks some examples would be neutrons and protons for a little bit of context the LHC was built
to allow for the study of fundamental physics and what happens to particles when they Collide at super high energies
in this circular tube by doing this scientists hope to learn more about how the early Universe came into existence
and like I previously said it was also used to find the Bon which is an elusive particle responsible for mass of
fundamental particles now in principle the interactions of these particles could be
simulated from start to finish with a sufficiently powerful quantum computer we're not quite there yet but progress
is being made now the Sher model is a simple model used to simulate some of these Dynamics and has emerged as one of
the most popular models of choice the details of the model are not super super important for right now but for those
curious it is a model that describes the behavior of electrons and positrons interacting via photons in 1 + 1 D
Dimensions meaning that there's one spatial Dimension and time the model has a lot of similarities to Quantum
chromodynamics which describes how quarks and hadrons interact now that's extremely hard to simulate so the
schwinger model is often used as a toy model to invest some phenomena that are actually common to
both now the way we are going to proceed with this example and the rest of the examples I have selected here as well is
by asking ourselves a series of questions the first is why did we have reason to believe that simulating this
on a quantum computer would work at all in this case the electrons and positrons in the schwinger model have a screening
effect causing correlations between distant Fons to Decay exponentially with separation and this means that there